well they're gonna put me in a in an
orange suit and we're gonna we're gonna
do it it's a big it's a big it's based
on the original pilot of the show
actually which I never sold which is
kind of interesting because television
and storytelling the television was very
different back then than it is now so
it's kind of like a combination of
strange old style sets they've been
redone and and and and this new show
that we do now what else is coming up in
season nine that fans could be excited
about you know what's that oh yeah well
would dress like you know like we're
from the 40s so we have this really
interesting I mean you don't want to say
it's interesting you got to be the judge
of that but we flash back to the 40s and
we get to play these characters from the
40s yeah that's good question ask us
because we've been doing so many
episodes that they all just seem like
the same thing so you know I mean it's
all just a big which on that it's it's
it's this that's why I'm this one kind
of stands out a little more to me
because it's that's funny because they
dress funny and it's a dream sequence so
it kind of tokens funny a little bit you
know and it's just we were able to kind
of just make a bit of a departure away
from what we do each day and then do
something a little different it's still
sort of in the ballpark but it's fun I'm
having fun I'm fun right now yeah Canada
people weren't up up Megan's been here
for a year and do her second season
how's that going we're not gonna talk
about we're talking about us she did a
75-minute interview talking about
herself
I love Megan I love Megan she to me
she's she's the reason to watch the new
episodes because for us it was like a
breath of fresh air and awesome talented
funny young lady to hang around with and
act with and so I'm a big fan of Megan's
and that's why I'm still here
combination and the way the writers have
given you dialogue or the way that you
create dialogue is one of the favorite
parts of the show that everybody seen
in endeared - and they enjoy so much
talk about that I mean that's my
favorite part of doing the show getting
to play around with him and pretend and
a relationship that between us and the
writers have come up with that's you
know that's the solving cases is a
little less interesting for us because
it's a little more you know detail and
the gun goes here and this goes there
but the relationship between us is when
we really have a good time I mean if it
looks like if it looks like fun it's
because we're actually having fun you
know those are the fun parts of doing
the show after I think we read the pilot
nine years ago now it was like Scott and
I both kind of we're riffing a bit and
playing around we were reading the words
but it was it was evident that we both
sort of had a similar energy when it
comes to sort of finding rhythms and in
the different parts of the story and and
and that leads to things like ad-lib to
get to the point where you are actually
having fun it's not I don't know how to
fake having fun it's not some of this so
we I don't know how much of it ends up
in the show either I struggle watching
myself so I don't do that but it's I I
yeah it's it's enjoyable work